let's talk about the uh the paradox of
anti-racism yeah
these woke people say that they are
anti-racists but as we know according to
max kennedy uh anti-racism means
actively participating in discrimination
geekwire writes trulia to drop
neighborhood crime data from home
listings after redfin speaks out against
practice you're going to love this one
they say
given the long history of redlining and
racist housing covenants in the united
states there's too great a risk of this
inaccuracy reinforcing racial bias
christian taubman redfin's chief growth
officer wrote in december 13th post we
believe that redfin and all real estate
sites should not show neighborhood crime
data
there is something profoundly racist
about
taking down crime data and saying it's
because it's racist isn't it paradoxical
disgusting
because the implication of course is
that black people
right don't also want to know
where crime is
so they could avoid it right it's so
disgusting
yeah i guess they think
it's like they have this everyone should
experience all of the crime that way no
one it's not one group that does
yeah equality everyone suffers is that
so disgusting the erasure of the victims
of crime
like the it's because it embarrasses
white liberals that the perpetrators of
these violent crimes are people of color
that embarrasses them right because it
doesn't fit with the anti-racism where
black people are the oppressed and white
people or the oppressors they are
willing to erase the victims of these
crimes children being gunned down in
their neighborhoods every day and no one
will talk about it the issue with with
uh uh crime in big city and big cities
and in this country is always poverty
you take a look at impoverished white
neighborhoods you'll see a high level of
crime you take a look at black
neighborhoods and poverty high levels of
crime and what they do is they put a
racial component on it which makes
everyone immediately assume the crime is
race-based
it's a class issue that's my big problem
i take with with wokeness it's basically
it's a scapegoat for the wealthy elites
as you mentioned it's a class issue but
they disguise it and it makes these
liberals feel good without having to
actually change anything they're not
going to move from their white enclaves
they're just going to pretend like
they're doing something by removing the
crime stats from from their websites
meanwhile they all know where they're
living they all know where they come
from they all know what they want to do
and how they want to do it
anti-racism is very racist yes and chloe
valderrae i believe said very
plaintively called it um
counter-dependence so you can have a
co-dependent relationship with racism
where you're like blatantly racist and
scream at people like you're worse than
me but having a counter dependence on
racism is also racist
trying to trying to use racism to combat
racism because you hate racism and
you'll use you'll go to any lengths to
stop racism including be racist but
makes no sense a lot of this is racist
for what reason does redfin or trulia
have to remove crime data this is just a
virtue signal and this data isn't going
away just because they're not putting
this filter on top of the map anymore
they have the data their rich allies
have the data the people who want it
will get it the normal people will not
have it and this that's disgusting
that's the hypocrisy you're talking
about i'll tell you exactly why i can't
stand uh
the democratic party
and overwhelmingly the establishment
left
they are willing to ignore reality for
the sake of tribe and certainly the
trump supporters have that element too
but they're not in power they don't
control cultural institutions
and i just look at um
covet data i take a look at the vaccine
mandates the mass command dates i take a
look at how they virtually signal this
way i take a look at how they tell
people we want to just black lives
matter so they want to disrupt the
nuclear family even though we know the
nuclear family is a huge component
really it's related to success
and a better living
when it comes to
all of these policies
rich people are exempt they're always
exempt rich person wants crime data they
simply go to a service and they pay the
money and they get it right and if you
if you're making millions of dollars
what do you care about spending a
thousand bucks on crime data but they'll
remove it for you the average american
when it comes to vaccine mandates and
mass mandates rich people don't got to
worry about it when it comes to air
travel oh no everybody's got to wear
their mask they want to fly in planes
joe biden says maybe we'll do a vaccine
mandate for air travel the rich person
says let's take private why do i care
it's always something negative for the
poor and the working class
i just you know i take a look at going
back to the trump years
you had americans suffering
these small towns were being gut and
destroyed by neoliberal policy sending
factories overseas
and then when these people
said we need help and many of them
wanted bernie sanders hillary clinton
wins they say okay we'll take trump the
response from the elites is you're all
racists and you're perpetuating white
supremacy and and this is where we are
today the the aftermath of all this fake
virtue signaling garbage yeah this
article reminds me it's kind of similar
to what happened on the view in 2015
when we had uh kelly osbourne said we
can't kick the latinos up because who's
going to clean our toilets
so this
air on is television and when you look
at a lot of these kind of locusts when
you look at a lot of these kind of
anti-racist apologists
many times these individuals are
the biggest racists themselves because
they believe that they're better than
other people and that they need to help
them because they're so much better in
in all circumstances than than other
people because of their skin color that
that viewpoint is absolutely absurd and
it's it's
nighting to the absurd levels this
explains the white progressive so well
authoritarian elitist and racist all at
once
but guilty about it
i i i think you know i i was talking to
someone i worked in la for a little bit
i lived there for a little bit and
people were telling me that celebrities
are really scared they're really
superstitious so they donate a lot of
money to various causes because they're
worried about karma you know they do
this movie they make millions of dollars
and they feel bad that they're living
this way so they give money away
this is kind of the same thing
there i think i think a better way to
explain it is warren buffett when he
said i can't remember exactly what
happened with this but he was like we
should do a pledge to give away half our
money or something you remember that
luke i remember that yeah and i i don't
think it had anything to do with him
actually caring i think it had to do
with him hedging his bet that there was
going to be a class war and people were
not going to tolerate his wealth so he's
like i'm giving stuff away
so when i see this stuff these are white
supremacists with guilty consciences
these these liberals these progressives
they're deeply racist individuals they
push deeply racist policies they've
actively tried to get civil rights
legislation repealed in california what
which proposition was that where they
tried to repeal from their california
constitution the civil rights provision
no joke they tried to remove that
because they said well once we get rid
of it then we can help the poor
minorities by giving them preferential
treatment and i was talking to a friend
of mine who's an la celebrity woke
whatever
and she was advocating for this saying
we need this proposition it was they
called the affirmative action
proposition that by removing the
non-discrimination non-discrimination
clause from our constitution we will be
able to help poor minorities go to
school and get better jobs and better
government contracts and so i asked my
friend
what percentage of california is white
what is it like 70 can you pull that up
i think it's upwards of 70 percent and i
said do you think and and what about
like central california and a lot of
these smaller towns what percentage what
percentage white do you think they are
and she's like oh i probably like 99 i
was like yeah do you do you think these
people are all racist you think white
people are racists 71.71 and she's like
yeah i think you know white people are
deeply racist and i said okay so when
you take away
the constitutional provision that bars
racial discrimination
and give a 71 white majority the ability
to discriminate do you think they're
going to all of a sudden give up that
power or entrench it
that's what that's what they i think
honestly i'm not so worried about the
small town white you know uh majority
putting up you know
whites only or anything like that i am
worried about these progressive
hollywood types who will be like oh well
you know why can't we do that they've
already done it in seattle with their
you know they had the um
what did they say diversity uh people of
color room and non-poc room yeah have
you seen these yeah when they set when
they start segregating so forgive me if
i don't trust these activists when they
claim they're doing it for altruistic
reasons dude it's like bill gates really
quickly actually make a reference
because there's an example i could make
here when he said he was going to give
off all of his wealth to charity he
literally doubled his wealth in a few
years so that that's the type of
individual sorry go ahead well i just
needed to say i wonder how many times
you got to see a movie where the guy's
like quick give me the ultimate power
item quick quick and then you give it to
him and he's like yeah thank you and he
turns and uses it on you and you're like
dude like
you don't get i'll give that kind of
authority to somebody i i don't really
believe that if california got rid of
that provision in their constitution all
of a sudden all the white people would
be like now so a chance
but that would ultimately eventually
happen in a no no no no no no no
what i mean is for my friend to claim
that she's you know she's woken she
believes white people are all racist
right to then want to give the white
majority the power to discriminate
against people based on race makes no
sense
and they won't back away from it her
response to me was yeah well you know
it's the right thing to do and i'm just
like
do you actually care about the logic of
helping poor people or is it just i'm
gonna say whatever my tribe tells me to
say so i'm popular
okay but we have two parties in this
country
and one of my big gripes with
republicans is like okay it's true
you're not all white supremacists but
where's your counter offer
to fix the remaining problems that we
have with racism like there's nothing
there there's nothing doing you would
think they would be showing up in the
black community and saying hey i'm going
to give you school choice get your kid
into a good school and i'm going to put
the criminals away so your kid doesn't
get shot on the way to that good school
and they don't show up well so the
republican establishment doesn't but the
populist republicans are starting to do
that we're starting to it's true well so
that's that's right very very slowly and
it's sort of we need we need everybody
to primary every establishment
politician be a democrat or republican
and then we can get some democrats who
say the exact same thing as republicans
say the same thing and because populism
is is the answer regardless of your
economic position i don't care if you're
a laissez-faire populist or a communist
populist if we find key issues we're
going to work together on and then we
can argue about the rest of it excellent
right instead what we have is the
democratic establishment is obsessed
with trump the republican establishment
just obstructs and then we get we get
nowhere as as you know americans who are
trying to actually solve our problems to
live better lives
this is why i think one of the reasons
trump wins at the very least trump was
like i'm going to bring your factories
back i'm going to bring your jobs back
i'm going to deal with the opioid crisis
i'm going to deal with our border crisis
we're going to end these foreign wars
far from perfect a lot of these things
but hey he didn't start any new wars he
triggered you know he set the timeline
for getting us out of afghanistan he
tried getting us out of syria he did
bring many of our factories back joe
biden comes in everything falls apart
once again i feel like now they're just
the establishment politicians namely the
democrats here's what i see happening
let me slow down
it was always the same with the
democrats and republicans the unit party
bernie and trump staged an insurgency
from the left and the right bernie is
weak he gave in he caved and now he toes
the line he has been absorbed into the
machine donald trump is a crazy person
who kicked the door and screaming and
took over and now a large portion of the
republican party is controlled by trump
and his supporters there still remains
establishment democrats in control but
they're slowly being weeded out mitch
mcconnell lindsey graham these guys in
my opinion are awful even ted cruz has
proven himself to be weak and feckless
then you do have a lot of populist
republicans who are a little too
aggressive but it's better than the
establishment in my opinion the
democrats have doubled down and
redoubled their efforts the neocons who
were booted out of the party jumped
sides to the democratic establishment
with like the lincoln project and now
start towing all of that line so that's
that's it the unit party is in the
democrats
they are extracting as much as they can
from this country as the ship is sinking
mitch mcconnell his whole attitude is
well i'm going to stand here and do
nothing and be a speed bump while the
democrats are like the only thing you
should care about is donald trump then
nancy pelosi goes buy more stocks as i
change the laws they don't i don't
believe any one of these politicians
save a small handful
actually care about making this country
better i think for the most part they
all see it as what can i do to ensure my
family's wealth and success because the
country is collapsing that's what i see
across the board so my hope now is that
come the primaries people go to the
republican party and they vote out every
single one of these establishment
republicans all of the and then you get
some working-class individuals uh
american populists and the same thing
happens to the democratic party i hope
the democrats get some
you know i i it doesn't really fly on
the left but moderate working-class
populist center-left individuals to get
rid of the democratic establishment
corporatist crony garbage and the woke
trash and then the republicans needed
the same thing to the neocon war hawks
and corporatists as well
and then repeal the federal reserve act
of 1913. yeah otherwise we're headed
towards zero yeah we gotta get rid of
that stupid corporation man
[Laughter]
i don't know i feel like
decentralization is our best bet
less centralized power at the federal
level you know is our is our best
opportunity because right now what's
happening is both sides are trying to
fight for supreme power
this is actually the first time in
history that it's been
that it's never been better to create a
decentralized government
what gives you hope tim like what what
is your positive vision like what yeah
i mean uh well gun rights wow uh-huh
that's fantastic uh gun rights have been
winning across the board and that it
says more than just guns it says that
regular people are are focused on their
individual responsibilities autonomy
yeah autonomy there is still an uh a
semblance of also a lot of people expect
the country to fall apart
but i actually i'm i'm uh it's i
wouldn't say any of this is pessimistic
i think it's fairly optimistic i think
the uh populism is winning
the the uh
day after day we can see that anybody
who toes the establishment line is is
mocked ruthlessly and insulted and
derided and they're not going to survive
politically adam kinzinger is the best
example he he comes out and he tweets an
insult at jack pasobic and i'm just like
bro you you're not going to win a
re-election if you're against jack
posobik jack is a very prominent
conservative personality millions
million plus followers or whatever it is
a big podcast so you don't gotta i don't
the left doesn't like the guy but on the
right
they love him if you're a republican and
you're like i oppose what these people
stand for you may as well leave so these
establishment guys are going to lose i
think the same thing's going to happen
on the democratic side 26 democrats have
announced their retirement because they
know they're done kinzinger announced
his retirement he knows he's done the
establishment is broken it's falling
apart cnn's ratings are in the trash our
ratings are through the roof crowder
glenn greenwald jimmy dore success
across the board for populist
personalities who actually believe in
the working class
i this great news i think the night is
always darkest for the dawn things may
get pretty bad i do think we're on the
verge of some major conflict that's
going to happen
national divorce could precipitate some
serious fighting over resources but
ultimately i think
it's going to be
it's going to get a lot better you know
if you believe in the strasshau
generational theory then we are in the
fourth turning the period of tumult in
crisis and that means after 2028 things
are going to get really really good and
we're going to have 40 years of growth
and prosperity 20 years of stagnation
and then 20 years of crisis and collapse
again so you know what's marked for 2029
what peak graphene
what is that graphene's carbon
take a drink everybody
it's a material like um and it's going
to be it's carbon but they figured out
how to make it as a monoatomic layer
just one layer atom thick layer of
carbon i've got amazing properties i've
got using building materials in the 21st
century pure carbon you can get out of
carbon dioxide we can withdraw the
carbon dioxide make buildings out of it
basically
i got this guy a christmas present tim
got me graphing for graphic design
um but the market has i did was doing a
lot of research 2018 looking down in
chile to build a company down there to
start producing it and everything was
pointing to 2029 as peak the year that
global society is gonna embrace graphene
we we have a button you can't see it and
whenever we feel the conversations going
in circles i press it and a big thing
lights up saying graphene and it flashes
and then accuse ian to just also shock
it shocks me it does yeah i'm under my
seat in case my eyes are closed there's
a dmt one for the after show yeah
but but to kind of ask you what what
gives you hope and to kind of also while
you're you're here i think it's fair to
say that we kind of see the solution as
very differently
but we agree on the problem we agree
that obviously the billionaires are
controlling too much of our existence we
believe that the banks have absolutely
printed money out of thin air we believe
that we're controlled by multinational
corporations that call the shots
populism has never been heard by the
government is there hope for us
working together somehow from these
different perspectives on these larger
populist ideas do you see populists from
the left and right potentially ever
coming together
i get hope from
going around the country talking to
people everywhere who are working class
who are
completely
don't care what their who their
neighbors voted for who are totally
postpartisan
partisanship is a completely elite
phenomenon because elites make money off
of it
and so i get a lot of hope talking to
working-class americans because um
they have hope
and i think that the but but i guess
yeah i still feel
stupidly like
i don't know
i don't know how we
how we do it without um
i still i'm struggling to have the
vision that you have like to see past
the current moment so i feel a little
bit like i'm still struggling to point
out like to the media itself like hey
you guys are corrupt could you be a
little less
working-class people are human can you
treat them better you know like i feel a
little bit like i'm but i feel super
hopeful about america i love this
country and i i think that it's it's
people are getting better and better
every day like i think that we've seen
a huge huge revolution on the right in
terms of how it thinks and talks about
race and how it thinks and talks about
things like police brutality very
recently criminal justice stuff like
that so i get tons of hope from the
unity i see
everywhere except in the elites thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 00 pm
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you